8 news now covering the homeless crisis
as well all across the valley we've been
telling you stories about it for weeks
now we thank you for staying with us at
4 30. I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Vanessa
Murphy tonight Neighbors near U.S 95 and
Russell sharing what they've been
experiencing as Madison Kimbrough
discovered it's more than just the
homeless encampments near their property
but a smell which they say is making
them sick Madison
yeah burning eyes dizziness nausea
that's just some of the symptoms that
residents say they've been experiencing
this past month now as you can see
behind me there is a homeless encampment
and many feel like the problem seems to
be coming from the smell
I smelled a strong chemical smell in the
air one night and uh they came over they
investigated and they came to my door
and they told me that it was most likely
chemical fumes from the homeless that
were burning trash in the flood channel
it's one thing to feel unsafe in the
area you live due to homeless but for
Sandy Welch who lives right by us-95 and
Russell she and her neighbors sharing
exclusively with 8 news now how sick
they feel due to the smell of trash
burning by their homes I thought it was
a chemical spill I called the fire
department I said I smell this really
strong chemical odor it's like really
strong outside my front door tires vinyl
rubber any kind of synthetic materials
like that I did go to Urgent Care on
February 4th because I was having
extreme dizziness Sandy's neighbor
Carrie cash wheeler experiencing her own
symptoms similar to Sandy's burning eyes
burning nose sore throat wrote all of a
sudden my lips will start burning and it
comes about the time that the sun's
setting and it's getting cold out
according to Carrie and Sandy Clark
County Fire Department confirming the
smell was from the homeless burning
trash and while this isn't a property
issue but a county problem the property
development team knows all about it I
have left a message with our property
management I was on board for the past
two years so we're they're aware so
what's the next step contacting their
County Commissioner to see if the
problem can be resolved I've been inside
the whole time I've been feeling so
terrible I couldn't walk to my mailbox
without wobbling
I reached out to the county and plan on
speaking to commissioner Jim Gibson
about what can be done this is his
jurisdiction reporting near U.S 95 and
Russell Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now